des images fortes captées sur le vif des
visages de gaspésia qui nous rappelle
que la vie d'avant n'était pas si facile
la photographe allemande jacobs avait ce
don de rendre beau des gestes répétitifs
presque aliéna comme transformer la
morue salée séchée et on voit déjà en
tranches et la morue on voit des gens en
aient une barge sur la grève voit des
enfants un peu un peu partout ce
territoire dont on sent vraiment la vie
on voit aussi la vie on voit ce que les
gens les gaspésiens et gaspésienne
faisait durant un voyage en gaspésie à
l'été 1954 il a su figé dans le temps
une période où les gaspésiens vivait
presque exclusivement de la mer comme
une sorte de chronique historique
ça correspond typiquement a vraiment au
moment où les américains vont faire de
la gaspésie une destination touristique
internationale et parce qu'à l'époque
tout le monde se rappelle les caravanes
en aluminium des américains alors
monsieur jack kirby était dans cette
mouture ou l'art de 800 road trip qui
avait fait avec sa fiancée à l'époque
moment émouvant et leonard cohen jacobs
revient en gaspésie assister au
lancement de l'exposition de son mari
décédé en 1993
am very much novartis je me sens très
émotive
cela me rappelle de très bons souvenirs
de l'homme que j'ai aimé elle était
accompagnée de ses deux filles pour la
circonstance ici bruno lelièvre
radio-canada à gaspé